hello and happy offseason spice Lords
this is Sean Evans checking in hot one
season six it's right around the corner
the premiere is next month
but that's not why you're here I know
why you're here it is time for the hot
ones season six hot sauce lineup reveal
this year only one sauce is keeping its
spot is an extreme table makeover Scovel
Edition and you know what that means for
the other nine it is out with the old
and in with the new
last year's lineup is probably the
closest we've ever come to a Platonic
ideal for what the hot sauce lineup
should be a triumph in sequencing in
spice in flavor but if we've learned
anything from Kobe Bryant it's when you
reach one peak there's another peak and
this year we just keep climbing and I
know everyone's always complaining they
whine Sean we want it hotter hotter
hotter hotter and this year we're
cranking things up significantly
especially in the front half where we'll
be lighting people up in ways that
you've never seen before and we're going
to start with the howler monkey taking
over the beloved no big deal slot on the
board is howler monkey original a
Panamanian style take on the tangy
vinegar-based hot sauce category the
peppers scotch bonnet the flavors garlic
and turmeric the first pitch of the game
is just a fastball right over the plate
strike one and then in at number two its
heartbeat hot sauce company's red
habanero let's take a moment to admire
this beautiful bottle first
squeeze technology then you have this
lovely heart chili pepper graphic it is
so beautiful to look at I love a good
label detail and get this it's from a
place called Thunder Bay Ontario shout
out to Canada
shout out to Matty Matheson a hot ones
hot sauce number two spot if ever it
existed and then at number three one of
the more unique sauces we've ever had on
the table
pirates lantern pepper sauce created by
a couple of brothers from Brooklyn and
based on a family recipe from Barbados
a punch of mustard a pop pop pop of
scotch bonnet peppers an aromatic hit of
horseradish and what's that there's rum
in it maybe Tyra was telling the truth
when she said that she got drunk on hot
sauce and then at number four
torchbearer
it's a name that the hot ones fans
recognize and it's back Ghost Pepper its
main source of heat but it's balanced
with a hint of honey sweetness and apple
cider vinegar and I know what you're
thinking Sean thanks for introducing the
first four sauces but what the hell has
happened to hot ones fiery Chipotle
spice Lords we need to talk today we say
farewell to one of our own after four
glorious seasons
it's a tearful goodbye to hot ones fiery
Chipotle a guest favorite a fan favorite
hell my favorite but if there's one
thing that I've learned in this crazy
game called hosting a chicken wing show
on YouTube it's that change is good
evolution is necessary so it's with a
touch of sadness but a soaring feeling
of gratitude that we say farewell to hot
ones fiery Chipotle and boom welcome to
the family los calientes and dare I say
it's even tastier than its predecessor
we worked with heatin ax stood aisle in
that California meets Mexico flavor
profile went through over 50 iterations
before finally settling on this elixir
of the gods expect a smoky blend of
serrano and habanero chilies sweet fruit
and tart tomatillo mmm that is good copy
and if you're a subscription box
subscriber you know the drill
you're gonna get Lowe's calientes first
and for the rest of you you get your
chance when we dropped the bottle in mid
June but that's enough about Lowe's
calientes because the flavor train just
keeps moving and we're on to the back
half and number six
it's another maker you've seen before
with a sauce you have in spice Lords say
gutentag to bravados black garlic
Carolina Reaper sauce that's right
knowing Chris thought it'd be a good
idea to trigger my Carolina Reaper PTSD
two-thirds of the way through every show
I'm so excited I can't wait but I'm told
that this bad boy is balanced out with a
kiss of maple syrup and the rich savory
bass notes of black garlic and the
number seven spot it looks like a bottle
of Johnnie Walker Black Label but this
ain't no civilized fireside chat this is
hot ones damn it so you know we had to
crank the thing up to 13 with Munsters
Black Label our first ever hot sauce
straight out of Australia and it is
packed with culinary ingredients orange
juice scorpion and Birds Eye chilies
goji berries we very much welcome bun
stirs from down under to the terrordome
and speaking of terror the bomb is back
guests complain about it or hot sauce
guru says that it's terrible and that we
should replace it immediately but just
like the laptop from my cold dead hands
and listen I do not want to eat another
chicken wing with the bomb on I really
don't but I'm a humble TV host and they
have to do what's best for this show and
in this case the best thing for hot ones
is to keep the bomb beyond insanity
putting guests on their heels knocking
them up against the ropes testing their
will to complete the hot ones challenge
so it keeps this place on the table but
as you know as you can see you've been
peeking at it we have a new number nine
Hellfire hot sauces furry fools all the
proper credentials for the number nine
slot
let's read off this pepper list seven
pop primo Carolina Reapers Trinidad
scorpions it is a hot sauce gathering of
the Juggalos and you even have a [ __ ]
up clown juggling Carolina Reapers on
the label and that tells you everything
you need to know about this hot sauce
all right at number ten you think you
know but you have no idea
sure it looks like the good ol last dab
but you know what smoking adds like
he'll never leave well enough alone and
so brand new for season six we're
rolling out the double x edition of the
last dab featuring not only regular
pepper X but also the new mutant breed
chocolate pepper X what's the difference
well I'm happy that you asked it's all
in the heat profile double X it hits
you're right away then it disappears
only to come back and bury you again
throw your hands up like you're at a
damn dmx concert because it's about to
get crazy we'll be testing our new sauce
out on celebrities who have nothing to
gain and everything to lose
before getting you a bottle in July the
peppers they're growing it's smoked and
Ed's farm right now last dab double X
edition coming this summer and there you
have it it's the season 6 lineup the new
characters in our funhouse the paint
brushes we'll be using to make our
absurd internet art if you want to pick
up the trading cards heat and ass as you
covered you can always take a look at
past seasons old hot sauces just find
something that you like season six let's
do this one together spice Lords it's
coming at you it's coming at you
see you next month well there you go
that's a wrap just another video gone
alone screaming at the Internet to the
camera now Carolina Reaper is that the
hottest pepper in the world it is the
hottest pepper in the world very
impressive you ever put what in the boot
no I think that'd be a bad idea I think
I think I just wrote a really great bit
for this show for you yeah